-My next guest is a talented
actor and comedian
who voices one of the characters
in the hit Netflix movie
"The Mitchells vs The Machines,"
which is streaming now.
Here is Fred Armisen!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my God, Fred!
-Hi. Hi!
-Come on!
It is so good to see you, bud.
-It's great to see you.
-How you doing, man?
-What you are up to?
What are you doing?
[ Light laughter ]
-I'm hosting "The Tonight Show."
-Aw, that's so great, buddy.
[ Laughter ]
-You're my guest.
Hey, it's kind of interesting
that --
your head has never been bigger.
[ Laughter ]
-I had it enlarged.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
-This is pre --
This is pre-pandemic, or...?
-During pandemic, so dur-pan.
-Oh.
-I just had -- It's really easy.
It's not that much of a hassle.
You just get some shelling...
-Dur-pan.
-...that goes into the forehead
and some sort of shelling
that goes into the sides --
-Yeah, the shelling.
-It sort of expands.
Yeah, it sort of -- and it --
it takes a day at the most.
I was just out for a little
while, and --
-If you want, I can --
Fred, I can be your legs
if you want.
Like, maybe if you want to --
-Yeah, let's do that.
Can you --
[ Laughter ]
Let's see.
Ah!
Boy.
Sure is great,
just stretching out.
And got my pants on
and my shoes here.
My shoes look great!
Aw, man, these are dancing
shoes.
[ Jaunty music plays ]
♪ I like to dance ♪
♪ Ba da ba, do do do ♪
Ah.
Yah, yah, yah.
Ooh.
Oh, boy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, Fred. It's almost like --
-Thank you.
-It feels like you just
gave birth to me.
[ Laughter ]
Fred, it's good to see you.
I want to talk to you
about Record Store Day.
'Cause you're the ambassador for
Record Store Day.
That's a big deal.
I think it's awesome.
-It's great.
They do it every year.
And I love going record shopping
everywhere I go,
wherever I travel.
I really do stop
into a record store.
I know that you're really
into vinyl
and you've got, like, a whole
record room and everything.
-I do, I love --
-Right.
-Yeah. What was your first
record? Do you remember?
-First records I ever got
were Beatles records.
I lived in Brazil.
And my dad worked for IBM,
so we were there.
And, like, my mom would get me
Beatles records.
This is sort of post --
right after they broke up,
so there was, like,
Wings records and Beatles.
-Yeah.
-You remember, it was all
kind of the same thing?
And so then, I used to --
So this is one of
the first records I got.
-"Beatles Forever."
I didn't even know what --
What is that album?
-It was like a compilation
that they -- that Apple put out.
But this was, like,
on the Brazilian label,
so I used to think that --
[ Speaking Portuguese ]
-Wow.
-I used to just think
that they all had
this Portuguese writing on it.
-You know what
we should mention,
what dates are Record Store Day,
so everyone knows?
-That's June 12th and July 17th.
-That's right. They're doing it
twice this year.
Good.
I love that you're doing that.
You're a good man.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You don't do --
-Oh, I didn't --
I didn't say what year. 2029.
-No, no, no, we know.
No, no, no, it's this year.
It's 2021. That's not true.
Fred, you do voices
and characters.
You also do impressions,
by the way.
And I heard that you're working
on a new impression.
Can you -- Can you maybe
do it for us tonight?
-Yes, yeah.
So there's an impression
I want to do of --
These are Instagram ads
that I keep getting. Right?
So I got to put this back
like this,
a little bit, if you don't mind.
I keep -- I don't know
if you get these.
But it's like --
if I could get the band
to do, like,
a little Chillwave music,
'cause they love
demonstrating things.
[ Band plays soft music ]
-Uh-huh.
Oh, on Instagram, sure.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter continues ]
♪♪
Yeah, and it bends.
Oh, yeah, oh,
he can walk with it. Yep.
-Yeah, it's -- They always show
that it's portable.
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
That's a great impression.
-I see these all the time.
-I knew exactly
what you were doing.
I want to talk about your movie
"Mitchells vs The Machines."
You know, this has been
the number-one movie on Netflix
for two straight weeks.
Ever single day,
the number-one movie.
That's a pretty big hit.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-It's very funny.
It's funny for adults.
It's funny for adults and kids.
My kids love it.
But also,
I was laughing out loud.
It's well, well done.
Congratulations.
-I thought they did a great job.
Thanks.
It was -- Me and Beck Bennett
play robots.
-Yeah.
-Sort of malfunctioning robots.
So, yeah.
-Is that -- Is that it?
[ Laughter ]
Fred?
Fred, can you hear me?
Fred, my Zoom --
-Yeah, yes, I can hear you.
That's it, you know?
I don't -- I don't want to
go into the whole thing
about the whole movie.
It's just --
-Why?
Why not?
-I'm worried about how much time
I'm taking up --
Do you want me to go into
what the movie is about?
-Just do the beginning,
at least.
-Okay, so,
open on title sequence.
-Ah, forget it!
Forget it.
It's gonna take too long.
Title sequence.
Here we are. Back again.
Here we go.
And there we go.
-What is it that you want?
-I try to explain to you.
-What is it --
-And then you --
-Can I speak? Can I speak?
-And I go --
And then I try --
-Can I -- No. No.
You asked me --
-You said --
-You asked me distinctly.
You --
-I wish I had a mirror.
-You asked me --
You said, "What is the movie
about?"
-To show you what
you looking at.
No, I said to you --
-No.
What did you say?
I want everyone to hear
what you said.
You tell everyone.
What did --
-Don't tell me what to do!
You tell everyone what I said.
-You -- I'll tell you
what you said.
You said you didn't know.
-That's right.
And I meant it.
And I meant I didn't know.
And I didn't know
what the movie was about.
All right? I'm sorry.
Okay?
-It's a robot apocalypse.
There!
Now no one is going to see it
'cause they know what it is.
[ Laughter ]
-It's already the number-one
freakin' movie on Netflix!
-But who's watching it?!
-The whole world's watching it!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I want to show a clip
from the movie.
Here's the very funny
Fred Armisen
in "The Mitchells vs
The Machines."
Take a look.
-We are robots.
Let us go downstairs
and find the humans
who you cannot give orders to.
-Okay, cut it out.
-Hold on.
I kind of want to see
where this is going.
[ Can clatters, marker squeaks ]
[ Footsteps approach ]
-Glad those "robots" are gone.
-Now it's just us humans
with our very human faces.
-All right.
I just turned the corner.
I like these guys.
-Yes.
My human guy name is Eric.
-My name is also Eric.
-No. I mean Debra...
Bot 5,000.
-Idiot!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Fred Armisen, everybody!
"The Mitchells vs the Machines"
is available now on Netflix.